مساء الخير بعد كشف الاداره الامريكيه عن
الجزء الاول من خطه
لخطه السلام اول صفقه القرن ما اعتقد شيء
اني بقت في حاجه ملحه للانتظار بلعبه
الجزء الثاني لان الامور اصبحت واضحه جدا
وبعيدا عن التسريبات وان كانت التسريبات
كانت صحيحه ليست خاطئه اللي تكلمنا عنها
خلاصه خطه طب لما تيجي ترى الجزء الاول
وتتوقع الجزء الثاني هي باختصار شديد
ارضيه اقتصاديه مقابل تنازلات سياسيه
والادق مقابل تصفيه القضيه هي هي القضيه
وهي التربيه الاقتصاديه اللي ب تقترحها
اداره
القضيه واضحه جدا بيتكلم على ارضه عاصمه
ولاجئين يعني قيام حل الدولتين دوله
يهوديه دوله فلسطينيه على حدود ما قبل
سبعه وستين اي قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للاراضي العربيه اثنين عاصمه فلسطينيه في
القدس الشرقيه
3 حق امتلاك بين قوسين حق عوده اللاجئين
كان دائما مسار خلاف اللي تكلم على 750000
الخرق بعد حرب ثمانيه واربعين
ولا بنتكلم على اولادهم واحفادهم حوالي
خمسه سته مليون
طيب في كل الاحوال هو لا للارض ولا
للاجئين ولا للقدس الشرعيه فضلا طبعا على
باقي الحقوق الغير فلسطينيه زي ال ال اولا
فهذه هي القضيه في مقابل التنازل عن
الثوابت كل هذه الثوابت والقبول ب
يعني كيانات متناثره على جزء من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هناك ترضيه اقتصاديه
الاقتصاديه التي كشفت عنها وسائل الاعلام
ولا يتم مناقشتها فيما يسمى ب ورشه
العمل او في مؤتمر البحرين
يوم 26 و 27 من دون القائم من يونيو
القائم هو عباره عن خطه تتضمن خمسين مليار
دولار لمشروعات اقتصاديه ضخمه جدا من
المشروعات مش عارف ميه وستين ولا 170
مشروع هذه المشروعات موت موزعه على اربع
دول الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله تاخذ منها
خمسين في المائه يعني خمسه وعشرين مليار
دولار
ثم الخمسه وعشرين مليار دولار الاخرى
موزعه على ال مصر والاردن ولبنان خمسه
وعشرين مليار دولار ال اتخذها الى الاراضي
الفلسطينيه الهدف منها انه يعمل فيها كم
هائل من مشروعات البنيه التحتيه والطرق كل
الحاجات اللي ممكن تخفي العناء عن
الفلسطينيين وتقلل فرص البطاله وزي ما
بيقولوا تجعل حياتهم غدا قبل خمسه وعشرين
مليار الاخرى بالنسبه لمصر الموقف اصبح
معلنا ان هي لن تستقبل
فلسطينيين في سيناء
ولكن هم بيعملوها بطريقه ثانيه يقيم
مشروعات كبيره في محطات مياه مثلا ضخمه او
مطار يخدم قطاع غزه المخلوق لكن تكون هذه
المشروعات على اراضي مصر حتى تكون تحت
سيطره دوله صديقه ولا هي مصر وفي نفس
الوقت تبقى بعيده عن اي تغيرات في
التوجهات السلطه الفلسطينيه يعني تبقى
المشروعات بتخدم اساسا على الفلسطينيين
لكنها موجود على الاراضي المصريه و تحل
المشكله كما لمصر لانها تعمل مشروعات ضخمه
جدا في سيناء بالنسبه للاردن ولبنان
اختيارهم ليس عبثا فيهم عدد كبير جدا من
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين فالهدف هو توطين
هؤلاء اللاجئين ربما استقبال مزيد من
اللاجئين في مقابل مشروعات تحل مشاكل
هؤلاء
وربما تحل مشاكل كمان اقتصاديه للدولتين
المازوم تين الاقتصاديه التفاصيل في
المرحله الثانيه لكن دي يعني التصور العام
ترضيها اقتصاديه لفلسطين وتربيه للدول
التي سوف تساهم في انجاح الخطه هنا هل
الخطه بهذا الشكل يعني فكره التربيه
الاقتصاديه مبدا التربيه الاقتصاديه جديد
الحقيقه الكل اللي بيقرى التاريخ ومتابعه
القضيه الفلسطينيه على مدار سبعين سنه او
اكثر يدرك انها ليست بجديده ان فكره
محاوله ارضاء التربيه الاقتصاديه او
القراءات الاقتصاديه موجود منذ بدايه
القضيه قد يكون مثلا مثال في الخمسينات
كان مشروع كان فيه مشروع امريكي اسمه
مشروع جونستون على ما اذكر من سنه الف
وخمسمائه الف وتسعمائه وخمسين ومن 1953
1955 مشروع بيناقش على ان مبارده ذاك ان
مبعوث الاداره الامريكيه للمنطقه جونستون
نعمل مشروعات ضخمه جدا تحاول تخفيف الضغط
على الاردن وعلى الفلسطيني على فلسطين
وبالتالي يقبل بوجود اسرائيل داخل حدود
طبعا ما قبل سبعه وستين ما كانش فيه سبعه
وستين
المشروعات اللي ان اتبعتها كلها كصحفي من
التسعينات بقى مش بعرف في التاريخ كلها من
التسعينات كانت تتضمن جانب اساسي وهو فكره
الازدهار الاقتصادي
ومشروعات اقتصاديه مشتركه وكان دائما فيها
عنصرين اساسيين او هدفين اساسيين الهدف من
المشروعات الضخمه دي الى عزل تعمل في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه والاردن والمناطق
المحيطه كان الهدف الاساسي من
اولا خلا مساحه للتعاون ما بال اسرائيل
والعرب بحيث يكون تمهيد لعمليات التطبيع
وتطمين بالدرجه الاولى لاسرائيل انه هذا
السلام لن يكون على الورق علشان يكون شعر
الورقه تكون في مشروعات بنيه تحتيه اذا
كان بترول وغاز
ياهو محطات يعني المشروعات الضخمه دي الا
تخدم على اسرائيل والفلسطينيين معناها
وبقيه الدول المحيطه معناها انه اسرائيل
تكريت يعني يتم ضمها في المحيط العربي من
خلال مشروعات تخدمهم وتخدم دول المنطقه
الهدف الثاني وهو تخفيف وعلى عن
الفلسطينيين سواء داخل الاراضي المحتله او
الدول المحيطه لكن الهدفين او الهدفين
المباشره الهدف النهائي هو اقناع
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
بالجلوس على مائده المفاوضات وبدء التفاوض
القبول بحل الدولتين دائما المزايا كانت
التربيه الاقتصاديه
لاهداف دين تطمين اسرائيل تطمين اسرائيل
تخفيف الضغط على الفلسطينيين اقناع
الجانبين بالقبول بحل الدولتين دوله
يهوديه دوله عربيه وفقا للقرارات الدوليه
كان اللي موجود في قول الادارات الامريكيه
اللي تم يختلف من اداره للثاني وحدود
الدوله العربيه يعني على كامل الارض سبعه
وستين على الجزء من سبعه وستين على حدود
سبعه وستين مع استبعاد بعض المستوطنات
اللي موجوده على هذه الاراضي وتعويض
الفلسطينيين اختلافات اما الخطه اللي
بيقدمها الرئيس ونقلوا العبقري
فهي بتختلف من عده
وجوهريه شكليه الوجه الجوهري هو لنا لسه
الى حضراتكم عليه انه الخطط السابقه كانت
ترضيها اقتصاديه للتمهيد لحل الدولتين اما
خطه فهي ترضيه اقتصاديه لتصفيه القضيه
يعني اخذ الحاجات دي وان تماما مساله
القضيه الفلسطينيه بمعنى الحقوق الاساسيه
امام
يعني الاسرائيليين من وراء اصيب كانت
وهو انه يا ايها العرب لكم حقوق ولكنكم لن
تاخذوها لم تاخذوها ولم ياخذها واذا اخترت
الحصول عليها عن طريق الصراع ما احنا لن
نعطيها لكم اراضيهم واذا انت اخترت طريق
الصراع هذا الصراع غير متكافئ لانه يصب في
مصلحتنا نحن الطرف الاقوى الاطراف انتقد
وحاجه وتفضلوا في حاله معاناه وامراض
وحصار اقتصادي
وعمليات غارات وهكذا فان تم دائما الطرف
الخاسر
بدل ما تخسر والحكم التي لن نعطيها لكم
وتخسر كمان شبابكم ومستقبل ك متعلق بلوم
شيء احسن اقبلوا بالوضع الراهن
ولكن يعيشوا حياه كويس يعني اه فرص عمل
وفي اه اه مستقبل وتعليم وصحه بدي افضل
كثيرا وهو يراهن في المساله على امرين
الامر الاول ان ان صعوبه الحياه اه داخل
الاراضي المحتله بشكل لا يحتمل وزادت
الصعوبه بالضغوط الشديده اللي عملها
الرئيس تمهيدا العرض خطته ومهدد خط اخذته
الزعيم بيقولوا فلكل محابس المعونات
والمساعدات الامريكيه على الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي زادت معاناه الناس
انا ما فيش مدارس ما فيش الاونروا ما فيش
مساعدات ما فيش ما فيش ما فيش كل حاجه
وبالتالي علشان لما يعرض عليهم الخطه
الناس يتلقفها كما يتلقى في العطشان شربت
ما او الجائع اي اكل تقدموا مش بس فيه اذا
كان كويس
الحاجه الاولى اللي ب نراهن عليها اثنين
انه ب يراهن ان الدول العربيه الدول
المتداعيه و تعبان او حالتها سيئه جدا
وبالتالي يضغط عليهم
على الفلسطينيين الوضع باختصار شديد جدا
هل الخطه ترمي
عندها فرص للنجاح الحقيقه صعبه جدا
صعب انها تنجح لاسباب ايضا موضوعيه
ولاسباب شكليه السبب الاساسي اللي ما
يخليش الخطه تنجح انه عشان تنجح لازم
الاطراف تقبلها يعني لازم الفلسطينيين
يخبروا بها ولازم الدول المعنيه اذا كانت
الاردن مصر لبنان دول الخليج اللي هم
اصحاب ال بيسموهم الى ست يكون درس اصحاب
المصلحه في القصه يعني لازم يقبلوا اي
زعيم عربي يقبل بالخطه
ويساهم في انجاح
معناها انه تقريبا بيعمل عمليه انتحاريه
لانه لا يمكن ابدا ان يتقبل شعب عربي مهما
كان بعيد حتى عن القضيه فكره انه انه فيه
زعيم عربي يبارك على التوقيع على انه
ترضيه اقتصاديه في المقابل الامس القضيه
بالكامل
حتى لو هما بدو نوع من الخوف من الامريكان
موافقه لكنهم يعني اكيد هي تملص من هذه
الالتزامات
والازمه بشكل
نسبه بشكل الخطه حتى بغض النظر اللي هي
بدر القضيه كلها هي من تقوم على خمسين
مليار دولار خمسين مليار دولار دور محدد
قال لنا
هما بيقولوا حنا نعمل انه الامريكان مش
يدفع والحنان محمد دافع الضرائب وطبعا
اسرائيل لن تدفع اسرائيل ما تدفع الامور
تعتبر انها يستحق مساعدات ل هذا
الفلسطينيين رغم انه هي القضيه في النهايه
تصب لمصلحتها لكن فهو
انه دول الخليج بالدرجه الاولى تدفع وبعض
الدول الاسيويه بيتكلم على اليابان
الصين لان هم اصحاب مصلحه في استقرار
المهد اه وبعض الدول الاوروبيه اللي
عادتها بتدفع بردو لنفس الاسباب استقرار
الموضوع وبالتالي
تبقى مصالحهم محفوظه واستقرار في المنطقه
يعني الدول دي بالنسبه لدول الخليج
لحضراتكم ان حتى لو تعهدت شكلا خوفا من
الامريكان وبسبب الضغوط اللي بيضع وها
الامريكان عليهم بين قوسين اهمها بعض
ايران يكون فيه صعوبه في التنفيذ لانه اي
حد سرا او علنا انا ب ينتحر لانه ب يوافق
على الخطه تقضي على القضيه تماما اثنين
حتى لو كان مقتنع اثنين
الدول الاخرى في اليابان او الصين والدول
الاوروبيه صعبه لا تتعهد بمليارات لانه
الامريكان انفسهم اوقف لمساعده فتخيل ان
البروكر او الراعي الاساسي لعمليه السلام
اللي اوقف على مدار عامين كل انواع
المساعدات
على الفلسطينيين الوقت انه يطلب من الدول
الاخرى انها تقدم المساعدات اللي هو
تقديمها يعني قد ممكن يكون مقنع في كمان
اسباب شكليه تخلي القصه ما تمشيش
الامريكان يظلوا من على مدار سبعين سنه
بيحاولوا يقوم بدور الوسيط كلمه الوسيطه
او ال او نسب روكر الوسيط النزيه لكن
شخصيه ولا حاجه بمعنى انه ما كانش العرب
يعتقد انه هو على الحياه هو كل الناس
عارفين انه ما فيش وجهه للمقارنه ما بين
علاقه الامريكان باسرائيل وعلاقه
الامريكان بالفلسطينيين انما كان في
الحدود الدنيا اللي الامريكان كانوا ب
يراعوها لتمرير ال ال ال المفاوضات اللي
كانت تجري على مدار سبعين سنه في اشكال
مختلفه المرادين تم بعملها بطريقه بطرق
المعتاده اللي هو يوصل الى اقصى مدى ممكن
وبعد كده اعتقد زي ما عمل مع ال ايران انا
وغيرهم تعالى عوده المفاوضات
خالص بالنسبه لفلسطين لانه ولا يمشي مع
ايران لانه بيقول لهم انتم خلاص تاخذ نقوم
القدس وان تاخذ منكم
قضيه اللاجئين
وكمان هو
على ما اعلن طبعا بعد الجولان مراحل بحيث
كمان الى فكره ضم الضفه الغربيه او الجزء
الاساسي من الضفه الغربيه الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي من الصعب جدا انه ارادوا ال بهذه
الخلفيه ضد المفاوضات بين كل هذا القدر من
المنح لاسرائيل قبل ما يبدا المفاوضات انه
يقنع الطرف العربي مهما كان ضعيف بالقبول
والجلوس على مائده المفاوضات
الحقيقه انه
خطه السلام
زي ما بيقولوا كان تمخض الجبل فولد فارا
فهو الحقيقه الخطه والدتها وهم اه يعني
اتبعوا معنا الدكتور اه محمد كمال استاذ
العلوم السياسيه المعروف يعني كليه تعبير
لطيف جدا اه هذه ليست صفقه القرن صوره
القرن يعني يا دكتور اسطوره القرن هل يعني
على طريقه الحوار والناس اللي بيوقف وكذا
والصحراء والسحر الذي افعل المسرح انشغلت
بحاجه اللي هي الفتره بحاجه وهو يعمل حاجه
ثانيه هو شغلنا بكلمه صفقه القرن وفضلنا
على مدار السنتين احنا والسياسيين وال اه
يعني التفاصيل ممكن تبقى وايه اللي ممكن
يفاجئنا بين ما هو زي اي ساحر بيعمل
الحاجه الثانيه بعد مشاركه انتباهك
المعامله صفقه القرن صفقه القرن الحقيقيه
انه خلاص رسخ في الاذهان التسليم بفكر انو
القدس لم تعد مطروحه على المائده انه لا ل
حق اللاجئين انه لا الضفه
للجولان التمهيد لضم الضفه الغربيه على
تصفيه القضيه تماما من بدعه والاهم هو
قبول او التمهيد والعمل على التطبيع وتم
باسرائيل في المجتمع العربي خصوصا بالضغط
عليه ومتخوف هم بشده من الخطر الايراني
رغم ان الخطر الايراني طبعا موجود لكن
بالمبالغه في بحيث انه كمان يحصل اضافه
اللقاء للحقوق اول كل ما حصل عليه
الاسرائيليين من الحقوق الفلسطينيه يحصل
كمان على تطبيع مجاني بدون سلام اشكركم
والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]